Okay. let's complete this thing. We are here in quote equals not quote.
This is control dependent on this earlier statement, which again reads from C,
that we have seen the dependencies of C before, but it also reads from tag.
So this is dependent on all the places that tag is being set, and then again this
is up to this one up here, and then again whether tag is being set or not, implies
a control dependency towards the governing conditions.
What is usually more interesting in the backwards slice itself, is what
is not contained in the backwards slice.
That is, the statements that are not checked.
What you are seeing here is the statements that are not part of the backwards slice,
are statements that refer to out, setting out, checking out, and returning out,
but nothing of what happens to out actually has any effect on tag at this point.
And this is precisely what the backwards slice gives us.
It tells us if we want to know why this statement was executed.
Well, we know it can't depend on out, because there is no dependency of tag
towards out in any way, or out cannot influence the value of tag in any way.